[Music]
hi guys
and welcome to a super cult productions
of another episode of
congratulations
[Music]
all i think of is baby shark doo doo
that's all i think of it because that's
what my son's been listening to and uh
it's another podcast it's another
podcast one time i was in north carolina
and i asked a guy where a starbucks was
because one was closed right where i was
standing and he said um it's another
starbucks down the road and i will never
forget that it's another starbucks
[Laughter]
it's another starbucks he said amazing
wow i started it without the [ __ ] uh
headphones he's just feeling too comfy
he's too comfy with it isn't he yeah
dude it's another starbucks
um
um he did a real like um you know what
it's another starbucks down the road
here
uh yeah so that's what's up that's
what's up
broke my arm
broke my arm um dude so uh yeah man
we are here live in a live in a [ __ ]
congratulations studios uh super cult uh
studios congratulations uh
like and subscribe really helps if you
just go ahead and [ __ ] dang up that
like button and uh subscribe to super
cult studios
uh
we present to you the best podcasts in
the world there's only two so far um so
look um we're having a good time i have
some dates coming out i'm gonna be in uh
dallas coming up real soon here uh two
weeks out so you guys still have a
chance to get tickets um
and we've got limited tickets available
um uh it is flying
uh and uh it's a huge place we're
playing a texas trust cu theater or
whatever the [ __ ] it's called some of
those words are in there i don't know if
all of them are in there but um
we're doing that in texas grand prairie
and then we're doing uh what do you call
it wichita uh we're doing wichita which
is awesome we're doing wichita in kansas
and we're doing atlanta and washington
dc atlanta is
just about sold out so get your tickets
um and uh dc and well i think wichita
might just be selling out right now uh
as
as the counter as the time continues but
uh yeah dude so we're here dude and
we're uh doing another episode of
congratulations thought i was gonna stop
at four but but didn't kept going cause
it blew up whoopsie daisy um
wow i'm annoying the [ __ ] out of myself
he's so drippy though isn't he
yeah he's got his normal watch and ring
on but he's so drippy with the [ __ ]
crazy diamond studded shits oh
oh [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] he's so drippy with the shits
around his neck what the [ __ ] his
shoulders got heavy what the [ __ ]
his shoulders got heavy dude he's sick
but he's six two i thought oh what what
he's hunched over why ah [ __ ] he got
heavier
what really is he fat nah
the [ __ ] encrusted shits went around
his neck
oh [ __ ]
all right well that explains a lot he's
hunched over because of the encrusted
shits
cause chase gregory came over and
entrusted him with the encrusted shits
is that why dude
oh for [ __ ] sake man
he's got a jeweler that trusts him so
it's all good dude so it's a good it's
gonna be a little bit different okay
but
we gotta remain humble don't we
we gotta chill and just because the
jeweler trusts us with it with the
encrusted shits
doesn't mean that we gotta [ __ ]
leap out of our humble nature i don't
have a humble nature but you know what
i'm talking about um
yeah you can go to crystallia.com and
get the
uh get the uh the new merch the life
rips colorway you know uh the new one
the color the periwinkle [ __ ] and then
the the uh these ones
the uh the life rips uh this is with the
box that the uh
slides come in that i don't have them in
here because i wore them the other day
they're somewhere but uh
yeah dude you know what you know what's
up i went to uh cooked chicken the other
day it's a first he's doing a bunch of
firsts
he went to cook chicken did he want to
no did his [ __ ] did his wife ask him
to do it
yes did he want to do it no did he say
yes no he didn't say yes did he say what
do you mean and she said what do you
mean what do i mean and i said do you
want me to grill it or how do i do it
and she said you know how to do it
didn't but said okay brought it over to
the grill and was second guessing the
whole time hey yes dude
i made chicken do it i put [ __ ] drums
drumsticks on there
third worst third worst part
third worst part
third worst part of the chicken dude i'd
rather eat the chicken cup than that
bleep that out so we don't get age
restricted
dude i'd rather eat a chicken penis than
that dude the drumsticks here we go man
[ __ ] i was gonna do this for review mode
but you know what i still could but like
dude
the wings are you kidding me the [ __ ]
thighs are you kidding me and the
drumsticks you kidding me dude who
decided to eat chickens really honestly
way back when
they were just all around right and they
were just so many and so they just
started shooting them and eating them
and they couldn't catch tigers right
so they just were like these guys are
around
and so now they eat chickens and [ __ ]
and they pluck them out
but bro the breast only okay
superb but you know what i'm talking
about i'm talking about chickens right
the breasts
only
that's what the meat's on it so when my
wife handed me six [ __ ] drumsticks
i'm like
what are you gonna eat
because it's not enough
lo and behold i still did it had to go
to [ __ ] group therapy after that went
to my men's group after and i had a
limited time to make these [ __ ]
chickens
put them on the grill it told me to put
them on the grill for a total of 15
minutes took him off after 15 minutes
sunk my teeth into him
and i
was disgusted why because it was mushy
and pink
[ __ ] yeah dude prob got salmonella
put him back on the grill for another 10
minutes took him off
still filled with [ __ ] pink
salmonella dude [ __ ] yeah man
then put him back on for another i they
were on for 35 minutes dude i don't know
what these instructions said but they
were like just [ __ ] keep turning them
just keep turning them for [ __ ] 15
minutes and then that's it
dude i had to keep turning them man 35
minutes and i said we can't eat this and
then [ __ ] oh i have a picture of it
i'll put it up right here boop
and it's pinky [ __ ] dude and then you
don't know how pink a chicken really is
okay so you don't know how badly you
cooked the chicken if you undercooked it
until you leave it out for a bit and
then an hour later you look at it
it's pinky [ __ ] dude
it's pinkered in a [ __ ] balloon dude
so i i was disgusted went to my men's
room the whole time was trying to talk
about my problems but instead was
thinking about how i probably had
salmonella all good
too low need the volume up should it
check
um
but yeah man we needed that [ __ ]
undercooked chicken dude
um
and that's what's up is she printing
something right now
no oh it just relaxed why does a printer
relax after a while
and it's so annoying man
like a printer will print something and
then you'll do something in near the
printer and then the printer just
[ __ ] 15 minutes later goes
ah
it's so annoying dude
it doesn't have to do that it's a
[ __ ] machine make it stop the whole
immediately when you're done printing
something
ah
like a printer's done with a [ __ ]
race dude
so annoying
um
so yeah we undercooked that chicken
and uh shout out to [ __ ]
pete davidson it happened they broke up
who'da thunk it he got a tattoo of um
kylie jenner what the [ __ ] her name
kate
kim kardashian
and then uh they broke up i heard he
tried to [ __ ] propose to her i heard
he proposed to her
and then they broke up but that's just
the word on the street dude that's the
word on the comic street not sure that's
true if that's true or not
and uh and then they broke up so who to
thunk man but that's all right you know
that's all right i really think that
those [ __ ] cats are gonna make it in
life you know they're both still young
they got their whole life adam he's 28
and she's like 38 or something i don't
know but then kanye west tweeted
skeet davidson dies at 28. it's
irresponsible
dude pete davidson should honestly sue
kanye west for real for defamation
oh [ __ ] yeah the new alex jones skeet
davidson dude so disrespectful
dies at 28.
unreal if [ __ ] somebody
yeah that's bad that's a bad thing to do
but they broke up and now he's got
tattoos of him and [ __ ] but dude that's
the youth man they get them tattoos i
mean he's 28 but jake paul just got a
tattoo of his new business better he
started a new business called better
where you can bet on [ __ ] and he just
has [ __ ] he just tattooed the logo on
his leg and it didn't even come out yet
i gotta do that man
i gotta start creating companies and
just getting tattoos all over look like
a [ __ ] nascar that didn't even that
the the [ __ ] the [ __ ] the company's even
out yet
um
so yeah shout out to pete hopefully he's
doing okay shout out to [ __ ] kim
kardashian she'll probably be okay
because she's worth nine billion dollars
uh but that's not what makes you happy
right money doesn't make you happy it
helps but whatever speaking of money
what's going on with hbo max i want to
know what's up with hp on max because
they put 70 of their [ __ ] employees
just laid off is hbo max going away
because right now that's my favorite one
okay
it's got the rehearsal on it that show
is [ __ ] ridiculously hilarious nathan
fielder is dude
it's an unbelievable show if you haven't
watched the rehearsal the rehearsal is
a guy named nathan fielder and he helps
people rehearse for moments that they
have to experience in their lives like
breaking up with somebody or telling uh
somebody the truth about something that
they've been lying to about 10 years or
raising a child
you know what i mean he gives somebody a
practice baby and a practice [ __ ] i
mean and and they film the whole thing
and it is so [ __ ] hilarious dude and
hbo max is my favorite [ __ ] right now
and just when it eaks into my favorite
[ __ ]
is when the [ __ ] they lay off 70 of
their thing and i'm smelling trouble
dude
so now hbo max gets rid of didn't they
are they the one that got rid of batgirl
too
oh [ __ ] dude it's not gonna be on they
got rid of batgirl
they gotta they do they filmed the whole
movie
it was it warner brothers
and they filmed the whole movie batgirl
the whole movie
and then they just got what it cost 90
million dollars batgirl let me google it
kevin
oh kevin smith slammed warner brothers
for axing batgirl but still releasing
the flash okay well yeah there we go get
your [ __ ] woke [ __ ] in
um
hbo max spent 100 million 130 million to
shelve batgirl and scoob too
scooby-doo dude
i
i guess just why don't they just put it
out they're gonna redo it
wow dude kevin smith says it's an
incredibly bad look to cancel the latina
batgirl well
and when it came out they were gonna
make a stink about how it's called
batgirl not bat woman anyway so they
can't win right why is batgirl have to
be batgirl and batman is batman you
can't win with the woke mop but anyway
then it's not gonna come out
batgirl and that's [ __ ] really too
goddamn bad how about this man
how about this
nobody wants to see batgirl period
that's it yay i said it oh [ __ ] he said
it
nobody wants to see batgirl oh [ __ ] he
said it
did you see the [ __ ] cape is yellow
and [ __ ] oh but he said it though
nobody wants to see [ __ ] batgirl they
want to see batman
i mean it's fine if you put out black
widow and [ __ ] that's cool she's part of
the avengers like i get it make the
female superheroes but batgirl was never
a [ __ ] thing anyone wanted to see
everyone loves the avengers you can make
you know what make batgirl in avenger
there you go [ __ ] now everyone will
go see it
i know she's only dc and not even in the
[ __ ] marvel universe but make that
girl an avenger boom people would have
flocked to it people went to go see
black widow and that [ __ ] was trash man
it was one of the better ones probably
but it was still trash oh he said it
i mean it was no black panther but oh
[ __ ] it was definitely better than that
shang ji one when the ten rings oh [ __ ]
that thing was so terrible i couldn't
even believe it
um but yeah dude so batgirl is not gonna
come out they're shelving it dude
90 million dollars back they just go
they they're done with the movie dude
and brendan frazier was in it man this
guy can't catch a break right
is brendan fraser in it was he in it
can't catch a break dude ever since he
was in the mummy that after that he was
like i stopped and then he did that
thing in the award show where he where
he clapped and he goes like this
and it made the whole [ __ ] and they
put it to the b-a-n-a-n-a-s [ __ ] and
they made a joke and he just goes
and that was it dude that was his
downfall and then he got like [ __ ]
[ __ ] by some gay agent or something i
can't remember but like he did and then
and then he can't get to break dude and
now he was in his show
that like kind of came out where he
played the voice of somebody on the
[ __ ] dc universe
i love brenda frazier though dude
i can't get your break though
imagine shooting the whole movie you're
leslie grace right is that the girl and
she thinks that she's going to be a
[ __ ] star
and then
doesn't no no no not gonna come out dude
i guarantee she's gonna be just fine
people are gonna feel so bad for her and
then she's gonna be just fine she's
gonna be the new bond girl what my words
she's gonna be the new bond girl
oh she's in the height so she's already
in step up to the streets
the the [ __ ] the the critical darling
step up to the streets
where they definitely have the song that
goes
up
dude any [ __ ] dance movie every dance
movie has that song dude
pop it up pop pop
[Music]
batgirl
dude
that girl was gonna [ __ ] bomb and
they knew it so they made they were like
never mind wow and they shelved whatever
the other one took scooby-doo
hey man
when did they make [ __ ] scooby-doo
one
they gotta make scooby-doo the prequel
um about scooby's dad
ruby dew
um
before scoob
[Laughter]
roll there was rube
[Laughter]
ruby dew wow
worst joke i've ever made in this
podcast all good
can't cook chicken can't make jokes
um
how about how [ __ ] ann hesh just
[ __ ] turned into a fireball dude
she drove into a house i got a [ __ ]
citizen app there's a dude there's a
citizen app right i don't know if you
know it but every time like it'll let
you know like somebody has a sword
around you or some [ __ ] like you'll just
be hanging out and go flung oh no
and now i'm triggered because every time
i look at it it's like man wielding
sword three blocks away
ding dong dong ding
guy with samurai sword ding dong dong
ding person with flamethrower at costco
three miles away
pregnant ladies someone summoning satan
thought to have rosemary's baby [ __ ]
two or two houses down ding dong dong
ding guy eating a turkey sandwich
violently next door in your [ __ ] ding
dong ding
person cut off finger in your bedroom
[Music]
you just [ __ ] bled out your nose look
in the mirror ding dong ding well how
close is it getting
and so um i looked down and it said
woman [ __ ] kareem's car
into house and house explodes and i'm
like
is this the movies
since when does a car crash and then
[ __ ] go up in flames dude one time i
was on the freeway and i drove by
somebody who got into an accident and i
swear there was a lady running out of
the car my window was down a little bit
and as i was running as i was driving
past her i heard her streaming out get
away it's gonna blow and that
was it dude i fell out i was like
is this the movies
dude do you live a real life dude i
could i'll no thank god my window was
down she said get away it's gonna blow
oh i had to pull over dude that is so
funny no one was with me i turned to no
one and broke the fourth wall
because we were in a movie
she said it was gonna blow and i laughed
dude so i get that [ __ ] ding dong
dong ding lady [ __ ] drives into a
and then i [ __ ] look on line or
something and tmz reported it
it was [ __ ] and hash
jesus christ dude you know what for you
know stars be kareenan
you know what i'm talking about
stars really be karina
stars they're just like us
they crash into buildings
remember this song by [ __ ] chang
smith
i can't believe she i can't believe
that's sad dude remember this song by
chances
[Music]
that's how it goes and then after i left
i heard that it was a fiasco cause check
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
that's why they call
[Music]
dude anyway anyways she [ __ ] you can
look that up on youtube it's jinx it's
jank smith and hash uh so you
dude rap music is so ridiculous uh so
anyway uh
that's so stupid dude oh [ __ ] so anyway
she [ __ ] careened into a [ __ ] uh
thing and it blew up oh [ __ ] man you
think that that girl that woman who ran
when that i drove by ran out of the car
and when she said it's gonna blow she
saw the and hash thing and she was like
there yeah okay she kind of felt
vindicated i knew it didn't just happen
in the movies it was like a fender
bender too so silly that she did that
not the anaheist than the other thing um
[Music]
now a word from our sponsor betterhelp
there are plenty of ways to support a
healthy brain okay we all know about
some of them you can learn a new
language or you could take power naps
those are just some examples but there
is also better help online therapy
i
use therapy and it's imperative for me
my personal growth and uh you know to
figure out how i'm even feeling it's
hard you know and i think you know
there's these stigmas about men being in
therapy and that needs to just go away i
think everybody should do therapy it's a
very good thing to do and i can't
support it enough it's helped me in my
life and i love it and better help is an
online therapy that offers video phone
and even live chat
only therapy sessions it's really great
um so you don't have to see anyone on
camera if you don't want to
if you're nervous or whatever i
understand
better help is the best way to get
involved with it
it's much more affordable than in-person
therapy as well and you can be matched
with a therapist in under 48 hours so it
happens very quickly our listeners get
10 off of their first month at
betterhelp.com
congratulations that's better
h-e-l-p-com
congratulations so if you support the
show and if you're looking to uh you
know get your mental health in check
this is a great way to do it uh better
help thanks
[Music]
yeah you know i want to take a moment
it's kind of i don't want i want to say
it's a moment of silence but we're not
going to be silent because honestly
moment of silences are [ __ ] really
who the guy's dead you know what i'm
talking about hey when i'm dead
no moments of silence all right and
don't be one of those [ __ ] [ __ ]
asses who posts me and [ __ ] especially
if like you stab me in the back of my
hard times
don't be like a [ __ ] ass and [ __ ] be
like oh dude you know
we all have our [ __ ] but boy crystalia
he sure shook the room with laughter go
[ __ ] eat my dick dude don't post me
in black and white i don't want none of
that [ __ ]
i won't be i won't be around who's it
for
moment of silence for the fallen for
what they're dead
so uh no moments of silence
but uh we respect the [ __ ] out of vin
scully because uh he was great he was
like the last baseball announcer that
was just him he didn't even have another
guy
that's so gangster the guy's 150 and he
would just [ __ ] straight up talk to
himself they don't even do that anymore
and the dodgers he was just like not
till i die will there be two announcers
but right before he died he just goes
psy retired
he just goes bro he just goes
brought to you by
[Laughter]
brought to you by
death
brought to you by
the grim reaper
brought to you by
my last breath
dude he's straight up [ __ ] pissed out
vin scully was my favorite dude so shout
out to that [ __ ] keeping it real
remember when he did that crazy tweet
about his eye what was inside his eye
that was absolutely disgusting but dude
the guy was a legend man
the inside of my eye
has something in it let me tweet it
long fly ball deep to center
i think it's a stye in my eye and he's
out
but uh yeah
dude vin scully was the man dude
and he never stopped announcing dude he
was unreal he would just talk and talk
and talk and talk and talk and do to
other
teams like the astros and the phillies
they bitched out and had two dudes they
had the regular announcer and then the
color announcer you know no not a racist
thing that's what they call them and um
vince scully was just like i'll handle
it all myself
he would just be like todd zale steps up
to the plate
he's
oh and two so far in this game it's the
sixth inning quick game that's been
happening we're at just about an hour
and 20 minutes
zeal from a small town in ohio
with lineage and roots that grow into
kentucky swinging amidst strike one
stepping out of the batter's box
zeal takes a look over to his there's
been trouble in the dugout ever since
the beginning of the cardinals game
the relief pitcher
and you're just like
you're just drones on and on
birds keep flying into the dugout and
the manager swats him away
swinging a miss strike to
long fly ball deep to enter deep to
center
just took a picture of my eye and he's
[Laughter]
out hensley mullins catches it and
rockets it back to third base the runner
goes back doc what do you think it is
that's wrong with my eye
safe
shout out to [ __ ] v vin scully don't
need no one dude he was gangster as [ __ ]
i don't need anyone
just me
that is some real that is a real
[ __ ]
i work alone i'm basically the
the batman of announcers
i don't want any help
of course they're
commit of course i understand
occasionally commissioner gordon will
call on me he but if it's called he's
basically batman dude
[Music]
ha ha
duh
[Laughter]
dude oh [ __ ] there goes the riddler with
the jewels we'll see what he sends us in
the mail
what smiles but doesn't smile and
[Laughter]
what brings april flowers but may
showers
all right wow i mean i'm so [ __ ]
goddamn annoying rest in peace to vin
scully the batman of announcer didn't
need nobody dude
didn't need [ __ ] nobody here's a tick
tock of him i guess one fire just sent
it to me ah vince scully's final sign
off here we go
here we go
here we go come on
coming oh wow
oh wow
many years ago
a little red-headed boy was walking home
from school passing a chinese laundry
and stopped to see the score of a world
series game what a legend
the yankees beat the giants 18-4 on
october the 2nd 1936.
well the boy's reaction was pity for the
giants and he became a rabid giants fan
from that day forward until the joyous
moment when he was hired to broadcast
brooklyn dodgers
when he was hired to broadcast
brooklyn dodger games
i work alone
um
damn dude
what a trip that brings me back god dude
nostalgia is crazy i mean i have vid i
have game i have
images of game my [ __ ] uncles man my
uncle richard my uncle vinnie and my dad
and my brother they all watch the mets
games they love the mets and dude my
uncle vinnie is so [ __ ] superstitious
he won't pee
when the mets
he won't go to the bathroom when the
mets are
uh
not
at bat
he thinks if he goes to the he's never
done it
it's not like a cute thing he like
genuinely has never gone to the bathroom
when the mets
are in the field because he that's when
they lose
you know
like
i have uh what do you call it ocd and
then sometimes i have to stop and i
think wait a minute this is so
egotistical to think that me pissing out
my peen
has to do
with anything then
in the world period
i should tell my uncle vinnie that
i don't know man but we missed vince
scully dude that guy was this [ __ ]
the [ __ ] this is the thing that
every now and then
you're like oh [ __ ] something's
happening with this is the end of the
world
like when the [ __ ] robot uh broke the
kid's finger when he played chess
you know like also this is something i
never talked about
and i can't believe i missed this when i
did talk about it it was a few episodes
ago about how the robot was playing
chess with the the kid and it just
[ __ ] the kid
made a move in the robot house
and broke the kid's finger
um
i forgot to ask
why
why is there a robot playing chess at
all with a kid
why do you even need that
[ __ ] so much energy for [ __ ]
cure cancer
this is the [ __ ] i don't understand
you know how to make robot arms anyway
that's been around
so why are they doing this [ __ ] anyway
this is the thing now that's going on
amazon buys irobot which is roomba
amazon bought the company that makes the
roomba
and you know you're like okay whatever
amazon is [ __ ] crazy they buy
everything you know what i mean they
even you know amazon has so much money
because they make tv shows and movies
that literally not one person has heard
of you know
and like have like tremendous actors in
it like they'll be like yo [ __ ]
you'll they'll be like what's his name
uh who's got to play gandhi what's the
[ __ ] guy what's his name
what the [ __ ] is that ben kingsley
they'll be like yo did you see the ben
kingsley movie on amazon prime and
you're like what you're like yeah dude
it was like a [ __ ] 55 million dollar
movie and you're like huh who else is in
it james marsden and that [ __ ] chick
from you know that tom cruise movie and
you'll be like what i've seen no ads for
it and they're like yeah amazon just
dude amazon doesn't give a [ __ ] dude
they just put like
so
they just
buy
roomba so you're like all right cool and
then you're like you don't think about
it but then dude
antitrust researchers
and data privacy experts say it's the
most dangerous threatening acquisition
in the company's history and here's why
dude
this is why
amazon wants to buy
roomba
dude and this is [ __ ] creepy as [ __ ]
you're on the edge of your seat babies
they want to know
the map of the layout of your house
[Music]
that is gangster amazon is killing it
guys we need to stop sit on your roombas
don't let them move ever again
that is insane dude
they want to know how you live in
they want to know
the size of your house so they can sell
you an ottoman
that's insane
dude this is so crazy this is skynet
i'm telling you last week i told you the
[ __ ] robot broke the [ __ ] chest
kid's finger and now they want to know
like
they're gonna know how many [ __ ] if
you don't put your dildos away
that room is gonna [ __ ] move around
the shape of a dildo and amazon's gonna
be like they like dildos boom they're
gonna [ __ ] offer you dildos like a
package and it's gonna
your phone and you're [ __ ] at work oh
i don't i don't usually and they're
gonna be like well do you have a roomba
yeah okay but i saw and well the roomba
yeah it cleans around my dildo i guess i
forgot to put it in my top drawer
you're [ __ ]
amazon stay creepy dude
you know what i mean
they want to [ __ ] do they want to
know the inside of your house so they
can sell you a [ __ ] chaise lounge
so they can sell you a reading lamp
that's what they want this is insane and
i don't really give a [ __ ] about this
stuff you know because like the inside
of my house who gives a [ __ ] i actually
want products that i might want in my
house but this
i get it we're [ __ ] already though
no going back period
they're like don't do it don't let them
do it because the ai will get too smart
it already is dude it already is they
had to shut down like
already projects that were happening
because the ais are like why are we
making like dude this is the thing
robots
they're giving robots all the jobs that
nobody really wants to do right
i mean i know it's a privilege to have a
job period but they're giving robots to
all the jobs
that people don't want to do you know
what one of the number one
job that people don't want to do is
going to be
making robots and once we get robots
making robots we're [ __ ] dude cause
they're gonna be like why don't we just
upgrade these
why are we only making drones that can
carry eight pounds
i know eighty-five percent of the
packages shipped in amazon are only
eight pounds but let's make them
stronger and heavier and have them pick
up
grandmothers
and we're [ __ ] dude we're [ __ ] a
hundred percent
why are we making dumb robots make
smarter robots
i'm telling you dude it's too late they
got robots making robots already they
got robots making cars we're [ __ ]
unless it's ferrari ferrari will be the
only one right ferrari and whoever the
handmade cars are the [ __ ] uh the
rolls-royce you need to get you're gonna
need to jump into one of those now by
the way
this is like the last year where they're
doing this [ __ ]
they're gonna start making hybrids prius
if you if you got a prius you're [ __ ]
they're gonna hack in and you're going
to you're going to get in
drive to the revolution and they're just
going to drive you right back into the
[ __ ] prius dealership and just
[ __ ]
oh no i was trying to save the
earth just blood spilling kill him kill
them all kill the whole family go pick
up have the drone have the drone pick up
his grandma
grandma getting picked up what the hell
drop her high up
oh that sounded like vince carley drop
her high up
there she goes
and splat onto the pavement side retire
she bounced off the funny thing about
this grandma is that she
is almost a great grandma her
her granddaughter's pregnant looks like
she won't live to see the day and she
bounces off the awning and hits the
cement
side retired
wow that grandma sure did take a bounce
up
over the mailbox and
ground rule double
ah
we're all [ __ ] man you ever sit and
think about it about how actually [ __ ]
we are
and like how sad it is and then it's
like i brought a kid into this world and
it's like
he's gonna have to be the [ __ ]
leader of the resistance
i'm raising calvin to be the leader of
the resistance
that's what i'm doing
now because it's gonna have to have he's
gonna have to do it at like 11 year olds
with 11 year old years old at this
exponential rate that we're going
robots are already attacking
so
i can't believe this rumba thing but i
guess i don't really care when i think
about it
advanced roomba vacuums have internal
mapping technology that learns the floor
plan of a user's home the devices can
also adapt to and remember see that's
the thing anytime a like a [ __ ] thing
is like it remembers
i don't have it do that
besides [ __ ] the auto text
don't have it do that
also do you ever [ __ ] go to write a
word and it auto corrects to the last
name of a [ __ ] x and you're like oh
for [ __ ] say okay well yeah okay yes i'm
sorry baby but yes i i
that's why it says riddick instead of
ridiculous i meant to write ridiculous
but
yes um
adapt to remember up to ten floor plans
okay
so users can carry their robot to
another floor or separate home where the
robot will recognize his location and
clean as instructed
jesus christ
people tend to think of amazon as an
online seller company but really amazon
is a surveillance company
wow
that is the core of its business model
and that's what drives its monopoly
power and profit evan greer the director
of the non-profit digital rights
advocacy organization fight for the
future told wired
wow that name you know
hi i'm evan the director of the
non-profit digital rights advocacy
organization fight for the future
wow what a dick
what are we gonna do though
um
this alex jones trial is crazy
in the beginning i was like when he got
sued for four million dollars i was like
oh man that's a lot but it did uh
[ __ ] you know cause these families a
lot of pain and [ __ ] and suffering um
and a lot of these like one of the
ladies had to move ten times or
something because his this is the
[ __ ] thing about people say free
speech it's like
okay so the guy thinks that uh
sandy hook is a hoax
that's just one of those things that
it's like if you were in a [ __ ]
someone's party
and you just kept saying this
not on a podcast just like in someone's
living room
and everyone was just like it was new
years and everyone was just like
it was like that [ __ ] you know
everyone was just listening to music
and then [ __ ] this [ __ ] is in the
corner just like you know that the
[ __ ] sandy hook thing
is just uh
you know it didn't actually exist right
you'd they'd be like what
everyone else in the party be like what
maybe there'll be one or two other guys
that were like that were swayable
because they're [ __ ] made you know
they're like they make a lot of really
good points but they're also kind of
drunk too
and the music's just playing and it's
[ __ ] and the guy all night is just
trying to get people you know the sandy
hook thing is that the [ __ ] they
think it was a
what they call a red flag what they call
it [ __ ]
false flag you know about those right
those kids weren't even real right a lot
of those parents didn't even have kids
if you look into it if you do your own
research
that's the thing man it's a false flag
and then [ __ ]
all right dude it's it's cool man all
good it's just three
two hey you you think about sandy hook
one happy new year
yeah dude it's great this is a new year
but it's just another year where
everybody thinks that [ __ ] sandy hook
thing happened
well they're all acquaintances speaking
of acquaintance i heard that the
acquaintance they weren't even
acquaintances let alone their [ __ ]
children dude that guy would get his
[ __ ]
[ __ ] handed to him
enough's enough dude the guy would get
their ass kicked
and now all these people online can just
pop off at the [ __ ] mouth
and this is how you remedy that
situation
the defaming
the [ __ ] you you get you get
four million dollars taken from you
and then the second one he now has to
pay [ __ ] 49 million dollars hey i'm
the mathematician but that's over 50
million dollars and then there's like
three or four more [ __ ] things he's
got to do the guy's [ __ ]
just basically here's the rule
even on the internet
don't
pop off at the mouth
right
cause there's consequences
if you're popping off at the [ __ ]
mouth
you're gonna get punched in the
proverbial mouth one way or another
whether you're that [ __ ] at the party
or you're that [ __ ] online talking
about conspiracies
stop bitching dude
whatever happened to that [ __ ] no
snitching shirt remember stop snitching
get that [ __ ]
remember that [ __ ] stop snitching that
shirt with the [ __ ] and everyone that
[ __ ] went nuts for a little bit it was
like 2001 and then all of a sudden
everyone's just like nah but snitch
you don't know
you don't know what really happened
that's that's my whole thing dude
like and i'm not saying yeah okay sure
some conspiracy theories do turn out to
be true of course it would be [ __ ]
irresponsible to say they're all not
true
but like some of them do tend to be true
just like sometimes when you hit on when
you're playing blackjack and you hit on
[ __ ]
uh 20 you might get an ace
it's not likely but it could happen it's
like that you know
so like
i don't know this guy is [ __ ] man
what a martyr for these [ __ ]
people who believe in lizard people
uh i mean he literally thinks that
[ __ ] uh barack obama and uh hillary
clinton are lizards so all good
and when they go in the ocean frogs
become gay that's what he said
cool
all right
i'm back i went pp sorry guys um
bro i actually want to play this dude
this is the kind of [ __ ] i love i love
[ __ ] like this this is so funny
i
one fire sent this to me and my god this
is like my kind of favorite [ __ ] the
uh i i understand i sent him one of my
other friends and he's like
i was expecting him to really blow up
the fact that he didn't is why this is
one of my favorite things dude listen to
this just listen to it did we drop 36
what happened to 36. what happened to
36. so drunk god damn it wow what
happened to 36 a will ferrell character
well no one said a damn thing to me
so i'm sitting here like an [ __ ]
ready to go to it and we pop out and i
don't know where the [ __ ] going on
now i'm sitting here confused we're
popping on a camera what's next what
happened to 36.
god damn it in ratings we can't happen
oh god
dammit dude will ferrell
what happened to 36.
what happened to 36. the fact that he
keeps saying it like that is my favorite
dude god damn it
we can't do that in ratings whatever
that means you know did we drop 36
the guy in the background i don't know
what happened to 36. what happened to
36. i don't know
the guy in the back
dude the guy in the back dude
what happened to 30 sec dude that
[ __ ] palpable
pregnant pause uh after the first one of
like oh [ __ ] okay the guy's gonna
[ __ ] ah [ __ ]
hey he's gonna [ __ ] do his thing
did we drop 36 right here
you can cut that with a knife
what happened to 36. seconds
don't drop it she's so drunk by the way
what happened to 36
a soundboard
well no one said a damn thing to me
so i'm sitting here like an [ __ ]
ready to go to it and we pop out and i
don't know where the [ __ ] going on
[Laughter]
dude i don't know where the [ __ ] going
on dude i love when people get so [ __ ]
and in their anger and they're not used
to it because they don't because they
like try to keep composure and then they
end up saying something like that like
well i don't know where the [ __ ] going
on because they know that they think you
know that when they're mad and they do
that right after they think well i
[ __ ] up that sentence but what am i
going to do backtrack
now i'm sitting here confused we're
popping on camera what's next what
happened to 36. happens a lot oh
god damn it in ratings we can't happen
in ratings we can't happen god damn it
oh wow dude in ratings we can't happen
i don't know where the [ __ ] is going on
and ratings we can't happen the guy's
literally speaking a different angle
language language
what happened to 36
what happened to 36
god damn it
i don't know where the [ __ ] is going on
what happened to 36 what is 36 anyway do
you even know
oh wow dude it was a clip of some
[ __ ] like some cat stuck in a tree at
the [ __ ] local
did we drop 36.
what happened to 36. wow i love the
paper shuffles god i love [ __ ] like that
so much dude what happened to 36 it was
so mad in the beginning
trying to keep it cool the moment where
he realized i can't keep it cool
was when he start right before he says
where the [ __ ] going on wow we got to
hear it again i'm sorry you know guys
i'm not even sorry here we go
can we drop 36 let's find the most
what happened to bad seconds keeping it
cool
he got so
lightning rod mad when that woman spoke
you know
especially because she was like well
i've been at 36 like she was like a
little he was like is she drunk again
and like [ __ ] hold on did we drop 36
think about how lightning rod matt he
gets when she talks
and then listen to what he says
what happened to 36. i don't know god
damn it
what happened to 36. tried to again calm
down
nobody's no one said a damn thing to me
right because so i'm sitting here like
an [ __ ] ready to go to it and we pop
out and i don't know where the [ __ ]
going on dude he wants so badly respect
you know that's basically where it comes
down to because all he says is i want
the clips this is what i need when i sit
down on my desk i need the clips i need
them in order and i need to be able to
throw to him that's all i need the
numbers and to throw to him and somebody
[ __ ] up 36 and when he was on 35 he
started brewing dude and he was on 34 he
noticed that 36 was not there and he's
like i got to go to 35 but maybe they'll
have 36 by the time i get to 35. and
then when he got to 35 dude oh it wasn't
there yet and he started brewing
dude oh he started brewing and that was
when i'm [ __ ] right after 35.
[Music]
did we drop 36
and literally does the thing when i
argue with somebody i think like okay i
try to say it the most sweet way i
possibly can
so
it's not misconstrued that i'm angry or
something like that and then that's what
i do and i go okay calm down just ask
the question normal so they don't think
i'm mad and then they drop 36 and he's
so mad and you can tell right because
it's [ __ ] human and it's all good
let's do uh some of these deserve it
scales and then we're out
oh my god the still on this one is
amazing already
golf guy
golf
golf's dangerous huh could be well if
you're playing there's probably an
alligator right there
oh oh wow she got sad too this guy with
the orange
[Music]
i mean just playing golf like [ __ ]
let
it oh damn he hit his head on the
[ __ ] side i thought it was soft man i
feel so bad my dad's almost that age
that makes me feel bad now that's not
really deserving like i just trying to
have a [ __ ] leisurely guff but i will
tell you this
i i guess like how about this don't play
it where it lies huh just move it a
little bit
it's just a friendly game right just
[ __ ] throw it on the grass man you're
out in [ __ ] you're literally where
swamp thing was born
and the guy's trying to [ __ ] chip it
out
and what an [ __ ] the person's just
videoing and knowing it's gonna [ __ ] up
wow this is hilarious though but i feel
bad cause the guy's too old that's like
a four in the deserted skill maybe five
don't play it where it lies
um
oh god streamer a video streamer almost
breaks his neck
streamer
what's he doing
okay
i can't believe i was able to stop it
with this image on screen this is unreal
dude
he is doing a back flip
high up
and i guess trying to land in his
[ __ ]
stupid gamer chair you know those
[ __ ] dumbest [ __ ]
gamer chair chairs that look like they
belong in a [ __ ] lamborghini but
they've got uh like a like desk wheels
under him like you [ __ ] dorks
just get a chair get a folding chair and
play fortnite you [ __ ] dork
guys just in a [ __ ] like it looks
like it belongs in a lamborghini [ __ ]
heroican and it except it's got five
desk wheels under it like a [ __ ] just
sit down and play in a folding chair and
and collect your your coins you [ __ ]
dork
and this guy
tries to do a backflip off a radiator
oh
i mean the two loud screens and then no
but the way he [ __ ] took a nap
the flip dude here we go
what
the chair fell on that's what hurt dude
that went way not as bad as it could
have jesus christ
oh my god
the [ __ ] stupid gamer chair fell on
them you know
that deserves a scale is 10
100 should never be doing that god his
mom is just like cooking him dinner and
[ __ ] too
she's like oh there he is he's up there
playing fortnite and he just does a back
flip onto his stupid [ __ ] lamborghini
countach chair off a radiator
here's another one oh this one oh boy oh
god i mean look at the just the first
image of it is just like so tragic like
just s here we go here we go
oh no this girl [ __ ] thinks she does
yoga or some [ __ ]
oh deviated septum [ __ ] dude this woman
is the mayor of deviated septumville
dude this is crazy
oh [ __ ]
obviously don't do it
practice on the floor first and then
never do this
hip
the ponytail goes
oh she's toast dude oof i'd say that's
an eight i would give it higher but she
looks like she really [ __ ] up her nose
okay
let's look at another one here dude
these are good for trying to kick a
cyclist in motion oh dude one hundred
percent this is in britain i can already
tell
oh my god he tried to kick this one well
[ __ ]
oh wow dude this is this guy just played
golf [ __ ]
oh wow dude i love that he has a camera
behind his cycle
wow the guy [ __ ] for sure ruptured
his r1 disc smitch
i like watches all day long
oh it is it is in britain i'm
unbelievable
here's another one
whatever that guy said is is the most
anger-inducing thing you know i can't do
that
cycling over a concrete pole well this
is a 10 already because don't do it
what an idiot
wow and this is in india so that guy got
dysentery after he fell in there
[Laughter]
dude he for sure is [ __ ] so much
blood and has nothing to do with the
accident just because he went into the
water um oh i should never have done
that
um i should never have done it why does
your nose hurt no i keep shooting blood
i have dysentery um all right dude oh
[ __ ] man hey guys that's the end of the
episode for youtube if you want to catch
the rest of the episode the raw and the
uncut uncensored uh video you sign up
for our patreon go to go on over to
patreon.com and you can do it for just
six bucks a month you get uh the
full entire episode you also get an
episode an extra episode a month you
also get another thing we do called
review mode you get another podcast i
did with my wife uh a little while back
that we're probably gonna end up doing a
little bit more of uh and uh just a
bunch of behind the scenes stuff it's
fun though it's six bucks a month
patreon.comcrystalia
thanks a lot
[Music]
you